good morning Hank it's Tuesday so over
the next five years our families are
donating six and a half million dollars
to Partners in Health Sierra Leone also
we need your help but more on that in a
moment when I was in Sierra Leone
earlier this year I spent a day with a
community health worker named Ruth who
works for Partners in Health making
house calls to people living with
serious illnesses like tuberculosis or
HIV Ruth makes sure her patients are
able to take their medications and
refers them to a clinic if they need
further care and also she can help
identify high-risk pregnancies which is
critical in Sierra Leone because it has
the highest maternal mortality rate in
the world one in 17 women in Sierra
Leone will die in pregnancy or
childbirth one in 17 like many people
Ruth's education was interrupted by the
Sierra Leonean civil war which lasted
from 1991 to 2002 during those years she
also contracted HIV and she nearly died
before access to antiretroviral therapy
allowed her to recover her health and in
turn to find a job with PIH where she
can care for her family and serve her
community today Ruth is paid a living
wage by Sierra Leonean standards but she
is far from well-off and at one point
Sara and I were walking away to visit
some other PIH employees when I happened
to glance back and see Ruth slipped the
equivalent of $2 to one of her patients
a mother who was struggling to feed her
kids a second meal that day the family
was also being enrolled in a nutritional
support program run by PIH but Ruth
wanted to make sure that they could eat
that day and I want to be clear about
this it required far more sacrifice and
compassion for Ruth to make that
donation than it does for our family to
make this one but we're talking about
our gift publicly today in the hopes of
bringing attention to the many health
care workers like Ruth who need to be
supported by more robust systems in
order to address the maternal and child
mortality crises in Sierra Leone and I
do mean crises this is an emergency
10% of Sierra Leonean children do not
live to see their fifth birthday and
3,000 women in Sierra Leone will die in
pregnancy or childbirth this year they
will die of hemorrhaging that any
well-stocked hospice
could easily address they died because
there is no electricity to keep the
lights on during nighttime deliveries or
to keep blood for transfusions
refrigerated or they die because there
is no running water which makes it
difficult to sanitize tools and prevent
infection they die for want of
medications or for want of surgical
gloves or they will die because they
need a c-section and in Sierra Leone
needing a cesarean section is often a
life-threatening emergency a woman
delivering at home or at a local clinic
who needs a c-section will usually find
that there is no ambulance to take her
to the hospital and so her best chance
will be a long ride dying on the back of
a motorbike this is an emergency
but because it is an emergency that has
unfolded over many years it doesn't
receive much attention also the solution
isn't simple like it isn't ambulances or
clean water or electricity or more
health care workers its ambulances and
clean water and electricity and more
health care workers and much else
systemic long-term problems demand
systemic long-term solutions and that's
what partners in health is really good
at working with them over the last 10
years our community has seen their
success at helping to build health care
systems and impoverished communities
from Haiti to Rwanda and now in
partnership with the Sierra Leonean
Ministry of Health they are crafting a
plan to strengthen every facet of the
healthcare system beginning in the kono
district that means hiring far more
community health workers like ruth who
can make house calls to people with
high-risk pregnancies and those living
with chronic illnesses it means
strengthening primary care centers so
they can become safe places to deliver
babies and receive basic care and it
also means the building and support of a
maternal center of excellence at Koidu
government hospital which will have a
NICU and more operating rooms for
c-sections and also serve as a teaching
hospital that can train the next
generation of sierra leonian health care
workers 96% of PIH sierra leone's
employees are sierra leonian and i have
seen what they've been able to
accomplish through their commitment to
their patients even with extremely
limited resources Hank and I are not
experts but we have spent the last
several you
learning from lots of experts and in
that process we've come to understand
that lasting change happens best through
deep ongoing lasting partnerships which
is why we're making a long-term
commitment to PIH sierra leone not just
with our money but also with our
attention we are committed to following
the successes and challenges of this
project over the next five years and
hopefully beyond through video and photo
and audio updates and also through
interviews with sierra leonean health
care workers okay so before we get to
the money part of this there's one more
thing I want to discuss I'm often asked
why Sierra Leone and to me there are
many answers to that question the
Ministry of Health in Sierra Leone is
committed to making systemic change and
PIH is deep connections in kono allow it
to help make that change but also by
locating this project in the world's
epicenter of maternal death partners in
health hopes to show that radically
reducing maternal mortality in poor
communities is not like some pipe dream
it's a global imperative and just as PIH
has led the charge to expand access to
treatment for HIV and
multidrug-resistant tuberculosis with
this project they aim to show the world
that strengthening healthcare systems in
impoverished communities isn't just
possible it's necessary and can be
replicated around the world
alright the money so - staff support and
supply the maternal center of excellence
primary care centers and a broader
network of community health workers in
kono over the next five years we need to
raise about twenty five million dollars
in total the good news is that we are
already over halfway there in addition
to our six point five million dollars
Partners in Health has secured several
big donations but we still need to raise
a little over a million dollars per year
which I realize is a lot of money
generous folks from within nerdfighteria
have already come together to build a
matching fund of $120,000 per year so
every dollar you donate will be matched
up to that amount thank you so much to
our matching donors if you can donate
five dollars a month or ten dollars a
month or even more it will make a huge
difference you can donate right now at
PIH org slash Hank and John partners in
health is known for its efficiency and
effectiveness and I have seen how much
a few dollars can mean in kono Ruth's
donation showed me that also your
donation now can have a lasting impact
because when moms don't die in
childbirth their kids are more likely to
go to school less likely to be
malnourished and more likely to live a
healthy life into adulthood in the
months since I've returned from Sierra
Leone I have often thought of Ruth and
what might have happened if she hadn't
got access to antiretroviral therapy not
just the children who would have been
robbed of a mother but also the
community that would have been robbed of
a generous and deeply committed advocate
it is unacceptable that thousands of
women will die in childbirth in Sierra
Leone this year and that thousands more
people will die of illnesses we know are
treatable from typhoid to tuberculosis
that is unacceptable and we don't have
to accept it so I really hope you will
consider joining us in donating at PIH
org slash Hank and John and finally
having asked you for money I need to ask
you for something else as well
your attention the most valuable
commodity of all even if you can't
donate please know that paying attention
to the big structural challenges of
poverty really matters because we only
address the injustice 'as we see so
thank you for being here and for your
attention again the link to donate is
PIH org slash Hank and John Hank I'll
see you on Friday
PS so many people over the last year and
a half have helped us get to this moment
and I am grateful to all of them but I
especially want to thank Andrew John
Ruth and dr. berry at PIH and also Nicky
flaw and rosianna halse rojas on our
side of things also huge thanks to the
life's library community and our
extraordinarily generous matching donors
if you are in a position to donate two
thousand dollars or more to this project
and would like to learn more about
joining the matching team you can email
me at sparks fly up at gmail.com I will
be in comments to answer your questions
Thank You PIH org slash Hank and John or
PIH org slash John and Hank also works